do you know that AI actually cause developers to have fatigue
yes AI is expected to help us to be productive
but
the same tool is increasing the cognitive load and mental exhaustion
this is pretty much what we're facing
when it comes to using artificial intelligence
yes we know that the technology comes with a lot of benefits
but at the same time
if we really want to make sense out of this technology
we need to also understand the downside
and what is it that is actually costing us right now
first let us take a look at the artificial intelligence paradox
or the productivity paradox
if you're a developer
you agree that one thing you don't like to really do today is writing
code by yourself
because you realize that oh
if you're to write this code by yourself
machines does that very well
one other thing that the technology has brought to us as developer
is also suddenly
we now become judges so
we sit where we just allow the machine or AI
to produce certain results
and at the end of the day
we get to criticize critique and judge whether what the output is
is what we're looking for or we need to make certain adjustments
but again
one thing to note is that AI doesn't come to reduce our workload
yes we expect that with artificial intelligence
we should be able to reduce the workload and have more benefits
in some of this technology that we have
but in real sense that's not the case
in fact AI brings a lot of work alongside yes
why it allow you to do certain things quickly
expectations has also doubled
in fact tripled
people will expect maybe sometime ago
give you a couple of weeks
couple of days to get things done
right now people expect so much from you
and this is because people feel like there are machines
that can help you get some of these things done quickly
so no excuses for people expect so much from you right now
but the question is when do you begin to watch out for burnout signal
like how do you really know when burnout is coming to play for us
to be clear with what I'm trying to say
I will give you one story and this story happens to me
maybe you can relate well
at the end of the story we should be able to tell